I walk through the middle of the block
and I looked at both sides of Street it
was gone and I didn't want to break down
in the street and cry because it was
gone the history was gone they got the
people out then they tore the whole
thing down and built expensive housing
in the 1950s and 60s the federal
government forced 300,000 families from
their homes the human tragedy is in
Calculon this is the story of the
destruction and survival of one
community
Phillip Peyton jr. wanted to end
residential segregation in New York City
Payton was the premier black realtor
both today in 1905 he began buying and
leasing buildings in West 99th and 98th
streets to all white blocks on
Manhattan's Upper West Side
then he rented apartments to blacks
blacks will say why should they have the
opportunity to rent and this is
aristocratic part of the city West 99th
and 98th streets between Columbus Avenue
and Central Park West became home to a
community of musicians and writers
Arturo Schaumburg lived on 99th Street
along with James Weldon Johnson and
Billie Holiday
[Music]
[Music]
many families stayed on West 99th and
98th streets for generations my
grandfather came from South Carolina to
99th Street I was born I started
thinking about 99th Street and trying to
see how many people that I remembered
that lived in those houses my parents
were married in 29 West 99th Street
February 5th 1914
they were eyes watching you you could go
down the street you could count on my
auntie being and her top window looking
out the window I've been that do nothing
and by the time I got home my mother
know about it because somebody a nun
told my mother I really believe anybody
in West 99th West 98th Street loved it
and when we had to move we were just
devastated in 1949 President Truman
signed the National Housing Act creating
a federal program called a Bourbon
renewal there's vast unprecedented
federal housing from gave cities the
power of eminent domain substantial
areas of the city were taken from the
older the goal was to replace chaotic
old neighborhoods with planned
communities what was once a rundown
dying section of the great city of New
York has been recreated talk to people
about urban renewal oh what a great
thing we're doing for the poor people
the slum means disease and crime the new
projects mean health and happiness West
99th and 98th streets were declared a
slum in 1951 and everyone living there
was told they'd have to leave there are
definitions of slums you know the income
level of the families while these people
were poor that didn't mean that they had
a bad life as long as they had the
enabled everybody was aiming for the
same thing everybody would finish school
get a good job help support your parent
you know
we have a family it was togetherness
that I cannot explain to you any more
than the better than what I'm doing at
13 I'm looking forward to all these
things that my older siblings had
experienced and we had to move there is
a space in my life right now
that's missing because of that move the
new housing was to be built not by the
government but by private companies
handpicked by the city for the first
time in history the city could condemn a
piece of property and turn it over to a
private individual Robert Moses who was
head of New York's slum clearance
committee had the power to pick and
choose which companies got the condemned
land they would take over these large
chunks of it's credibly valuable real
estate imagine real estate Manhattan he
gave it out as political favors to his
allies in the Democratic Party all of
the contracts came through the political
clubs they gave to their friends who
were builders a realtor phony
corporations West 99th and 98th streets
and four surrounding blocks were sold
for a token sum to a group of local
Democratic Party operations five years
later the original buildings were only
partially torn down there might have
been a couple of houses people were
still living him there was some diehards
they wouldn't move we had no heat no hot
water we still stayed until it became an
emergency they had to get us out of it
[Music]
I couldn't understand why they wanted to
tell my home that it was not a swamp I
tell people I never left the old
neighborhood that is my village
that's my village
when I was young it was painful my man
and I got past that and I think most of
us did by remembering what was good and
the older I get the stronger that
feeling he gets I feel pretty sad when I
go by now so many memories we laugh
about it but yet it's a sad feeling I
feel that something was just taken away
from us
[Music]
you